Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim.
Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 112. Ausgabe von UKW.
Und ja, dann Großbritannien, derzeit eigentlich nichts wichtiges passiert.
Bleiben wir erstmal bei der Ukraine. Ich sage hallo zu Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau und wir wollen natürlich wie immer hier so unseren Take auf die Vorgänge
des Krieges in der Ukraine werfen und ja mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen,
was passiert ist seit der letzten Sendung, die haben wir veröffentlicht am 9.
Juni 23, jetzt haben wir den 27. also es sind nicht ganz drei Wochen vergangen.
Und ja gegen Ende der Sendung oder beziehungsweise im Laufe der Sendung waren
wir uns eigentlich relativ einig, dass die lange angekündigte Gegenoffensive
der Ukraine im Prinzip jetzt gestartet hat.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass es irgendwie so einen Startschuss gibt und jetzt geht's
los und überall wird angegriffen,
sondern es war eben so eine Verdichtung der Ereignisse,
eine Ausweitung der Kämpfe auf mehrere Orte,
Während es ja bis dahin im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur in Bachmuth und Einschränkungen auf Divka,
also in diesen Hotspots, die wir jetzt schon seit einem halben,
dreiviertel Jahr beobachten gab, sind halt jetzt einige neue lodernde Feuer
dazugekommen und das hat sich jetzt eigentlich auch,
bestätigt. Ja, ich würde sagen wir starten dann auch einfach mal mit einer Zusammenfassung,
was seitdem passiert ist.
Also es gab vor allem mehrere Vorstöße im Süden der Front. Das ist der sogenannte
Saporitia Bereich, also im Oblast Saporitia.
Da erstreckt sich halt die Frontlinie von einem Ort Vasilivka.
Das ist da, wo dieses Znipro-Becken, was jetzt kein Becken mehr ist,
auf die Sprengung des Staudammes werden wir im Laufe der Sendung auch nochmal kommen.
Also dort wo quasi das Libro Becken endet,
dort geht die Front mehr oder weniger gerade nach Osten bis sie dann so bei
der Stadt Donetsk langsam nach Norden abbiegt, hoch nach Luhansk.
Und an dieser Südfront, da gab es dann jetzt so mehrere Hotspots,
also je nachdem wie man so zählt, gab es so drei oder vier Bereiche,
Regionen, wo die Ukrainer Angriffe gestartet haben.
Das fängt dann quasi ganz links an, bei Vasiljivka,
da hat sich eigentlich auch nicht sehr viel getan,
das ist halt generell eigentlich ein sehr langsamer Vorstoß,
den wir jetzt erstmal sehen und das auf der ganzen Front, was ja auch viele
schon dazu gebracht hat zu sagen, so die Offensive, die ist ja total gefeilt,
da geht ja nichts voran und wenn das so lange dauert, naja, dann sitzen wir
hier in zehn Jahren noch und so.
Man muss halt auch wissen, wie diese ganze Front abgesichert ist.
Die Russen haben halt jetzt viel Zeit gehabt, dadurch, dass der Westen nicht
so richtig in die Pötte kam und dann erstmal über allen möglichen Scheiß diskutieren musste,
ja Panzer, mhm wissen wir nicht, ja vielleicht, ja dann doch,
wie viele, wo braucht ihr denn, ach so viele, mhm haben wir die überhaupt.
Es ging halt so hin und her und die Russen hatten halt jetzt im Prinzip an den
ganzen Südfronten ja Zeit sich tief einzugraben und das haben sie halt auch getan.
Das heißt es gibt dort eine extrem weite, weit ausgebaute Verteidigungslinie,
die erstmal so aus einer Frontlinie besteht.
Da sind meistens irgendwelche Trenches, die relativ dünn besetzt sind.
Da ist also nicht der Großteil der Truppen, sondern die Vorhut sozusagen.
Und vor allem ist dieser Bereich aber dann auch intensiv vermint. Dahinter...
Kann sich also 10, 15 Kilometer ausstrecken. Dahinter geht es dann eben los
mit noch stärkeren Befestigungen,
das heißt da sind so richtige Trench Networks, solche Grabennetzwerke,
die halt sehr sehr sehr weit gezogen sind in mehreren Linien hintereinander
und dann kommt halt auch irgendwann diese von uns sicherlich auch schon mal
angesprochenen Wagner Linie,
also diese Betonpyramiden, die da rumstehen.
Das ist dann so eine Kombination aus Gräben, diesen Betonpyramiden,
weiteren Gräben, die dann auch sehr tief ausgeschachtet sind,
einfach um hier einen mechanisierten Vorstoß mit Panzern oder anderen Fahrzeugen im Keim zu ersticken,
beziehungsweise das so langsam zu gestalten für den Angreifer,
dass man das dann eben effektiv verteidigen kann.
Und das wiederholt sich dann noch ein paar mal und wir haben es also hier quasi
mit einem Bereich zu tun, der so je nachdem wohin man guckt 20,
30 Kilometer tief aus Befestigungen besteht und da wird die Ukraine halt durch.
Und sie lagen jetzt erstmal an diesen Angriffsorten an dieser ersten Verteidigung
und machen da aber auch Fortschritte, auch wenn das mit starken Verlusten verbunden ist.
Was vielleicht auch noch erwähnenswert ist, ist,
dass jetzt nicht nur dort Leute jetzt in den Gräben sitzen,
sondern auch hinter der Front, hinter der Kontaktlinie,
so fünf bis 15 Kilometer dahinter,
ist dann eben auch noch Artillerie, die das dann eben auch besonders gefährlich macht.
Plus, was die Artillerie eben auch kann, ich meine auf beiden Seiten, ist Minen verschießen.
Das heißt, dass selbst wenn man jetzt irgendwo als Angreifer einen Weg geräumt
hat, dann kann der in kürzester Zeit eben durch Artillerie wieder neu vermint werden.
Und was die Russen auch wohl tun,
ist, dass sie dann,
wenn Truppen durch sind,
quasi die Minen hinter den Angreifer schießen,
sodass die angreifenden Kolonnen dann auch nicht ohne weiteres wieder sich zurückziehen
können und dann eben auch erstmal vom Nachschub oder Verstärkung abgeschnitten werden.
Das kommt also auch noch erschwerend hinzu.
Nicht einfach jetzt denken,
okay, weil wir es jetzt durch dieses Minenfeld geschafft haben,
ist alles gut, sondern wie gesagt, das kann halt sich sehr, sehr schnell ändern
und das ist eben alles sehr tückisch.
Das machen aber auch beide Seiten. Also das ist ja sowohl eine Strategie der
Ukraine als auch der Russen, also sowohl im Angriff als auch in der Verteidigung
wird diese Strategie angewandt.
Ja, also trotz alledem gibt es große Probleme mit Minen,
also gerade in den ersten Tagen gab es ja so ein paar sehr bekannt gewordene Verluste,
zumal ja die ukrainische Seite eine starke Medienstille verordnet hat,
das heißt man hat sich überhaupt nicht geäußert und tut es eigentlich auch bis
heute noch nicht so richtig über welche Fortschritte, sondern das waren dann
alles so russische Berichterstatter.
Überhaupt hat man das Gefühl, man wird derzeit eigentlich nur aus russischen
Quellen betankt im Wesentlichen,
so nach dem Motto, wenn die zugeben, dass die Ukraine irgendein Dorf erobert
haben, dann wird das schon stimmen, so als andere nimmt man dann halt mit Körnchen
Salz oder im Großen auch.
Aber es ist klar, dass eben bei diesen Vorstößen vor allem diese Minenfälle
am Anfang ein Problem war und
die Ukraine hat halt auch relativ neues Equipment zum Einsatz gebracht,
also es kamen diese amerikanischen Bradleys zum Einsatz, es kamen auch schon
deutsche Leopard Panzer zum
Einsatz und dann eben diese speziell diese minenfesten EBRAP Fahrzeuge.
Trotz alledem gab es so ein paar Desaster, wo das einfach alles nicht funktioniert
hat, wo man in zu großer Konzentration gestartet ist etc.
Fehler werden gemacht, wurden gemacht, wurden aber auch teilweise schon korrigiert.
Was es weiterhin erschwert ist, dass die Russen dort mit ihren Ka-92 Hubschraubern viel angreifen,
die halt so einen Raum von zehn Kilometern abdecken können, sozusagen aus dem
Nichts auftauchen und dann angreifende Fahrzeugkolonnen beschießen können.
Auch das ist sehr schwierig, weil halt der Ukraine hier mobile Flugabwehr fehlt,
die so weit reichen kann.
Einerseits und andererseits eben auch generell natürlich es mit der Luftwaffe
nicht so gut aussieht. Die Ukraine verfügt über verhältnismäßig wenig Flugzeuge,
haben wir ja schon drüber gesprochen.
Jetzt gibt es halt das Versprechen, die Ukraine umfangreich mit F-16 Flugzeugen
auszurüsten, aber das wird halt noch dauern, bis das in irgendeiner Form eine Rolle spielen kann.
So müssen sie eben quasi im Wesentlichen mit Bodenmaterial arbeiten,
sehen sich aber trotzdem einem Beschuss von Hubschraubern und natürlich auch
von von Kampfflugzeugen ausgesetzt.
Also das ist ein sehr schwieriges Vorgehen. Trotzdem.
Passen Sie sich der Situation an, also es werden auch die Vorstoßstrategien geändert,
das heißt man geht jetzt häufiger mit Fahrzeugen voran,
also mit diesen IFVs, also Infantry Fighting Vehicles,
also Fahrzeuge, die speziell für den Transport von Bodenpersonal,
also Bodensoldaten gedacht sind, die werden dann halt abgesetzt in so eine Angriffszone
und dann wird aber das ganze Equipment und auch Panzer wieder zurückgezogen,
im Idealfall auf irgendwelche Höhen, um das dann eben von hinten abzusichern
und sich eben möglichst eben auch dieser aktiven Gegenverminung zu entziehen und all das.
Also nichtsdestotrotz gibt es Fortschritte und in der Summe hat die Ukraine
jetzt schon sehr viel mehr Gebiet in Anführungsstrichen befreit als die Russen
zum Beispiel in Bachmut im letzten halben Jahr gewonnen haben.
Das ist natürlich jetzt alles für den Kriegsausgang noch nicht entscheidend,
weil Fläche gibt es da noch eine Menge,
die man zurückerobern muss, aber es zeigt zumindest, dass die Aktivitäten,
die sie entwickeln, auch von Erfolg gekrönt sind,
noch nicht mit total überstrahlendem Erfolg,
aber das Ganze ist ja auch nicht das einzige, was dort geschieht,
sondern all das, was jetzt so passiert und was eigentlich Teil der Gegenoffensive
ist, kann im Großen und Ganzen auch nach wie vor unter diesem Aspekt des Shapings gesehen werden.
Das heißt man greift mit relativ wenig Personal, mit relativ wenig Gerät an vielen Stellen an,
schaut wie die Reaktionen sind, guckt wo die Russen mehr gegenschlagen,
wo nicht, wo man sie taktisch umgehen kann,
wo man einzelne Geländegewinne machen kann, aber es geht nicht so sehr um Geländegewinne,
sondern es geht eigentlich darum die Russen zu zwingen in irgendeiner Form ihr
Material zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Also man möchte eigentlich auch, dass die quasi mit der Artillerie arbeiten,
damit die ihre Bestände verbrauchen.
Weil im Hinterland wird dann wiederum mit den neuen Langstreckenwaffen,
insbesondere Stormshadow, versucht den Nachschub zu zu unterbinden.
Und das funktioniert teilweise auch sehr gut. Unter anderem gab es Stormshadow
Angriffe auf zwei wichtige Brücken, die die Krim mit Kherson verbinden.
Das eine war eine Straßenbrücke, das andere ist eine Eisenbahnbrücke.
Die gelten jetzt erstmal als vorübergehend als unbenutzbar und das bedeutet,
dass eben eine ganz wichtige Eisenbahn und auch eine ganz wichtige Straßenverbindung
von der Krim, die ja letzten Endes wiederum ihre Versorgung über die Kertschbrücke
aus Russland erhält, dass die nicht so ohne weiteres in diese Saporitia Region fließen kann.
Paar Kilometer weiter, gab es dann auch noch einen Stormshadow Angriff auf ein
riesiges Munitionslager, ich hab jetzt gerade den Ort, den Ort wo das war, hast du das im Kopf?
Da gab es mehrere tatsächlich, du meinst jetzt den Bahnhof?
War das ein Bahnhof? Ja also direkt an den Schienen das Ding.
Ich glaube Rikowe war der Ort.
Genau und da gab es wohl ein riesiges Munitionslager und.
Wenn man sich die Satellitenbilder vorher und nachher anschaut ist schon
krass also da ist so ein kompletter Stadtteil quasi weggebombt der
aus diesen Lagerhallen bestand also Stadtteil ist ein bisschen übertrieben aber
es war halt so ein riesiger Lagerbereich und von diesen Gebäuden ist herzlich
wenig übrig geblieben das sagt eben deutlich aus dass das eben jetzt nicht nur
ein Bombardement war was dort für die Zerstörung gesorgt hat,
sondern da ist Munition dann entsprechend hochgegangen und es ist alles explodiert
und brannte noch tagelang und auf den Satellitenbildern sieht man auch,
dass da mal locker ein paar hundert Meter Eisenbahnstrecke fehlt oder zumindest
so starke Mitleidenschaft gezogen ist, dass da eben nicht ohne weiteres mal
ein Reparaturtrupp über Nacht das wieder fixen kann.
Also das sind alles diese Shaping-Operationen, die werden dann auch in anderen Städten gemacht.
Also generell diese Taktik, die wir schon in Kherson gesehen haben,
als die Russen über den Fluss gedrängt wurden, dass man einfach sagt,
okay wir verengen quasi eure Lieferwege in unseren Möglichkeiten.
Damals waren es halt diese beiden Brücken, jetzt ist es etwas umfangreicher
was man beschießen muss und wir halten euch aber auch busy.
Das heißt wir sorgen auch dafür, dass ihr eure Vorräte verbraucht und das ist
sozusagen jetzt die Taktik.
Nebenbei schauen wir eben, wo sind gute Ziele für uns, wo können wir dann auch
im unmittelbaren Kampfeinsatz was machen und man konzentriert sich zum Beispiel
auch extrem auf die Artillerie.
Also man versucht halt wirklich auch die Artilleriegeschütze selber mehr zu
zerstören. Es werden derzeit sehr viel mehr Artilleriegeräte zerstört als zum Beispiel Panzer.
Das ist auch aufgefallen anhand der Zahlen,
die die Ukraine gemeldet hat, dass zuerst
bei der Gegenoffensive eine
Menge an zerstörten russischen Panzern gemeldet
wurde und sogar Putin hat 56 zerstörte russische Kampfpanzer eingeräumt zu irgendeinem
Zeitpunkt nach Beginn der Offensive und war allerdings natürlich auch der Meinung,
es seien hunderte von ukrainischen Kampfpanzern zerstört worden.
Also wenn man alle Ziele.
Alles ausrechnet oder zusammenrechnet, was angeblich laut Russland die Ukraine
an Verlusten hatte, dann hat sie irgendwie ein Mehrfaches von ihrem gesamten
Material mittlerweile verloren.
Und Prigogine, auf den wir später auch noch im Detail kommen,
hat behauptet, man muss es immer mit Vorsicht genießen,
was er sagt, aber dass es halt einfach ein System gibt in der russischen Armee,
was es schwierig macht oder fast unmöglich macht, überhaupt die Verluste auf
der eigenen Seite und auf der anderen Seite vernünftig zu erfassen.
Weil und eben systematisches overreporting ukrainischer verluste und underreporting
russischer verluste angeht weil und das wird nicht nur einfach oben jetzt.
Von Putin oder so, dass der jetzt mit den Zahlen mauschelt,
sondern das passiert im Prinzip fast auf jeder Hierarchie-Ebene,
dass die Zahlen nicht stimmen.
Angefangen von, ja, einfachen Soldaten an der Front,
die eben Prämien erhalten für zerstörte Fahrzeuge des Gegners,
sodass dort einfach schon mal ein Incentive da ist,
mehr zu berichten oder, ich sag mal, so wie es vorgekommen ist,
halt diesen zerstörten Medrescher dann als zerstörten Leoparden auszugeben.
Das ist jetzt nicht nur reine Propaganda, sondern das ist auch,
weil ja, wenn es denn stimmt oder wenn man das meldet, gibt es halt Geld zwischen 50.000 und
300.000 Rubel, je nachdem, was man da zerstört hat.
Und ja, und natürlich nach oben, wenn nach oben Verluste gemeldet werden,
Ein Teil der Verluste, gerade an Personal, wird dann schon mal gar nicht erfasst,
sondern die werden dann erst mal möglicherweise als vermisst gemeldet, wenn überhaupt.
Und auf jeder Hierarchie-Stufe, wenn es nach oben geht, wird dann ein bisschen noch abgezogen.
Und bei den ukrainischen Verlusten aus russischer Sicht passiert dann eben genau das Gegenteil.
Und so ist das Problem, dass dann tatsächlich Putin,
Schoigu und Gerasimov nicht wirklich wissen, wie es denn aussieht oder wie es
denn bestellt ist um die eigenen und die gegnerischen Verluste.
Ja also gerade mit diesen Belohnungen ist natürlich auch noch ein weiteres Problem mit dabei,
wenn du dir jetzt vorstellst, da hast du dann irgend so einen Flugabwehr Spezi
und da greift dann irgendwas an, irgendeine Missile, die man eigentlich normalerweise
mit dem Gerät gar nicht gut abwehren kann.
Wo man normalerweise sagen würde so ja brauche ich gar nicht so probieren so
nach dem Motto aber jetzt kann ich aber hier 250.000,
Rubel verdienen für mich wenn ich den trotzdem treffe probiere ich es einfach
mal, baller irgendwie das ganze Kontingent einfach mal raus weil muss ich ja nicht bezahlen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann eben wirklich zum Abschuss kommt,
ist natürlich super gering und damit wird dann auch eine ganze Menge Waffenmaterial
vernichtet für gar nichts. Sozusagen nur so als Lottoeinsatz.
Oder es werden dann, gut das lässt sich nicht immer vermeiden,
es kommt immer darauf an,
wohin jetzt eine Rakete oder Artillerie wirklich unterwegs ist,
aber es führt dann eben auch dazu, dass im Zweifelsfall ja fünf, zehn mal so teure,
Abwehrraketen geschickt werden gegen eine anfliegende GMLRS-Rakete,
wo man dann vielleicht… A.
Ja, dass nichts passiert. B. Ja, also da gibt es eben schon gewisse Fehlinzentivierungen
bei diesem System, die nicht gut sind.
Also um es nochmal abzuschließen, man hat jetzt mehrere Vorstöße in dieser Südfront,
es gibt im Wesentlichen drei Regionen, eben Baselivka ganz links,
daneben Orichiv, da geht es noch nicht so richtig voran.
Die meisten Fortschritte wurden südlich von Velika Novoselka erreicht,
da sind also mehrere Ortschaften schon eingenommen worden und auch strategische
Höhen werden derzeit Eingenommen die dazu führen werden,
dass sich dort auf jeden Fall die Frontlinie noch weiter nach Süden ziehen wird.
Nichtsdestotrotz sind da noch gut 10 Kilometer Minenfelder zu überbrücken bevor
es dann eben zu dieser Hauptverteidigungslinie kommt.
Und ja dann wird es eigentlich erst interessant, wenn man diese zweite Frontlinie
erreicht, weil die ist bisher halt noch nirgendwo erreicht worden.
Außerdem gibt es jetzt auch noch Vorstöße nach wie vor um Bachmuth herum,
das nervt die Russen natürlich besonders, da gibt es jetzt für die Ukraine eigentlich
auch nicht viel zu gewinnen,
Weil Bachmuth ist ohnehin zerstört, aber dadurch, dass Bachmuth halt so ein
wichtiges politisches Objekt ist, weil sie jetzt so viel Energie und 100.000
Soldaten darauf geschmissen haben, diese Stadt einzunehmen und sie dabei zu
zerstören, dass ein Verlust binnen kürzester Zeit für Putin natürlich nochmal
super peinlich wäre. Nach dem Motto, was können die denn eigentlich?
Also, wenn man jetzt, um das mal zusammenzufassen oder das ein bisschen zu quantifizieren,
wenn man jetzt ein Progress Bar hätte für die Offensive und 100 Prozent wäre
halt jetzt das Asowsche Meer zu erreichen,
dann sind es irgendwie grob 100 Kilometer von der Front.
Und wenn wir gucken, wie viel jetzt im Rahmen der Gegenoffensive dort vormarschiert wurde,
reden wir von zwei bis drei Kilometern auf ungefähr halber Front,
kann man sagen, wenn man jetzt so die Südfront betrachtet.
Das heißt, dass der Progress-Bar jetzt irgendwo zwischen ein und zwei Prozent
steht, wenn wenn man jetzt nur den Geländegewinn betrachtet.
Aber wir wissen ja alle, wie unzuverlässig Progress Bars sind,
wie die dann oft ganz, ganz lange stehen oder sich kaum bewegen,
bevor sie dann irgendwie ganz schnell vorangehen und so kann man das vielleicht auch betrachten. A.
Ja und vor allem ist es ja auch nicht so, dass sie jetzt erst wirklich bis an
die Küste kommen müssen, bevor sie dort irgendeinen Vorteil haben.
Also wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel 10, 20 Kilometer weiter fortschreiten können
oder 10 Kilometer würden wahrscheinlich bei Novoveliska,
da würde es wahrscheinlich schon ausreichen, wenn sie nochmal 10 Kilometer Fortschritt erzielen,
weil dann wird es nämlich interessant,
dann könnten sie im Hinterland so viel Puffer haben, dass sie dort mit ihren
HIMARS Raketen sich platzieren und könnten dann eben auch schon so Orte wie,
Berdjansk oder Mariupol erreichen. Also das ist,
da gibt es so ein paar Tipping Points,
die ganz interessant sind und das ist ja auch so,
diese Vorstöße, die gehen immer so, ja für dieses Dorf braucht man lange,
für dieses Dorf braucht man lange und dann geht es aber auf einmal wieder ganz schnell,
weil man einen Weg gefunden hat, irgendwo einen größeren Bereich in die Zange
zu nehmen und dann ziehen sich die Russen halt auch drauf zurück,
weil sie sonst eben eingekesselt werden und dann alles vorbei ist. BK'IN DR.
Ja, aber man kann noch zusammenfassen, es geht, wie erwartet,
langsam und mühsam voran.
Und ja, es gibt auch so ein paar nicht so schöne Nachrichten,
zum Beispiel die GLS-DB,
Gleitbomben, die mithilfe von Raketen auch dann aus Heimatsystemen abgefeuert
werden, verzögern sich jetzt noch um ein paar Monate bis in den Herbst.
Eigentlich war man davon ausgegangen, dass sie im Juni kommen sollen und dann
auch noch helfen können jetzt, aber das wird wohl erstmal nichts.
Trotzdem, es gibt auch SBC, weitere Fortschritte.
Es wird zum Beispiel von einem neuen Brückenkopf berichtet, wo bei der Antonovsky
Brücke bei Kherson, wo es den Ukrainer gelungen ist mit einigen Fahrzeugen den Fluss zu überqueren.
Also da könnte es einen neuen Pressure Point geben und es gibt jetzt auch neue
Angriffe rund um Donetsk.
Es wird jetzt auch das erste Mal ein Gebiet angegriffen, was schon seit 2014
und nicht erst seit Februar letzten Jahres besetzt ist.
Das muss jetzt alles nicht viel bedeuten, aber zeigt, dass die ukrainische Armee
wirklich sehr breit streut und die Russen halt permanent unter Stress setzt.
Und es ist die Frage, wie lange sie eben diesem Stress standhalten können,
was letzten Endes dabei passiert. Die Russen versuchen ja auch mit Gegenangriffen
Ablenkungsmanöver zu starten, vor allem in Luhansk.
Aber da macht es auch nicht so den Eindruck, als ob die Ukraine dann gleich
mit großen Truppenverlegungen oder Nachrückungen reagiert, reagiert,
sondern sie sind sich da eigentlich sicher, dass sie das auch so halten können,
Eindruck macht es zumindest.
Ja, und was auch alle Beobachter mehr oder weniger übereinstimmt,
sagen Russen wie Ukrainer und auch ausländische Analysten,
dass die Ukraine aber den Großteil ihrer Reserven noch nicht eingesetzt hat,
also wahrscheinlich so größenordnungsmäßig ein Drittel im Moment der verfügbaren
Truppen für die Offensive eingesetzt werden,
während die Russen wohl jetzt tatsächlich eher 70 bis 80 Prozent ihrer Reserven committed haben.
So aktuell. Das scheinen so in etwa auch die Zahlen und Größenordnungen zu sein.
Und wenn das stimmt, dann könnte das eben auch bedeuten, dass in dem Moment,
wo der Druck auf die Russen durch die Ukrainer,
weil sie halt Fortschritte gemacht haben, weil sie die Nachschubwege entsprechend geblockt haben,
weil der logistische Aufwand so viele einzelne Angriffspunkte zu verteidigen,
all das, dass das so viel Überlastung erzeugt,
dass es dann halt auch knackt und wenn man dann im richtigen Zeitpunkt eben
die zweite und dritte Reihe dann auch noch mit dazu nimmt,
dann eben zu so einer Totalüberlastung das zuzuführen, um dann eben auch wirklich
einen Durchbruch zu haben.
Aber ich glaube davon sind wir noch ein oder zwei Monate entfernt.
Das lässt sich derzeit sehr schwer einschätzen.
Ja, und ich bin da auch eher so ein bisschen skeptisch, wenn ich mir das so
mathematisch anschaue, was da passiert.
Ist es ja so, was diese Angriffe jetzt auf die Infrastruktur,
auf Eisenbahnbrücken und Was die bewirken ist,
dass quasi die Bandbreite oder
die Kapazität, mit der Nachschub geliefert werden kann, reduziert wird.
Sie wird aber nicht auf Null reduziert werden, sondern eben um einen bestimmten Teil. und das ist,
Auch natürlich nur dann relevant, wenn auch tatsächlich ein größerer Verbrauch stattfindet,
wenn die einfach nur dort sitzen jetzt
und im Sommer ist auch der Treibstoffverbrauch dann nicht ganz so groß,
dann ja, ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass auch wenn es mit
Lkw und Pkw angekarrt werden muss, der Nachschub, dass das ausreicht,
solange es eben nicht andauernde intensive Kampfhandlungen gibt.
Und wenn ich mir so die Karte angucke, dann sehe ich jetzt nicht,
dass den Russen irgendwie so schnell der Nachschub ausgehen wird.
Also auf jeden Fall wird es eher noch schwieriger,
als wir es in Kherson erlebt haben,
wo es ja nur zwei Nachschubwege gab,
als die Russen dort nur waren, nämlich Nowa Karkovka und die Antonowsky-Brücke
und die beide ganz gut unter Feuer genommen werden konnten.
Selbst da hat es ja dann fast ein halbes Jahr gedauert, bis den Russen die Vorräte
ausgegangen sind, sodass sie sich zurückziehen mussten.
Und wenn man sich jetzt die Karte anschaut, ja, das Gebiet ist zwar deutlich
größer, um das es geht, was hier jetzt versorgt werden muss,
aber es gibt eben auch doch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Da Nachschub ranzubringen.
Also es ist nicht so isoliert, wie jetzt der besetzte Teil nördlich vom Dnieper war.
So würde ich das einschätzen.
Was halt.
Bedeutet, dass die Ukrainer sich durchkämpfen müssen und um einerseits ja schon
für einen gewissen Verbrauch oder für eine Abnutzung zu sorgen,
aber ja es wird sicherlich deutlich,
deutlich schwieriger werden oder ist deutlich schwieriger als die anderen beiden
großen, erfolgreichen Offensiven Kharkiv und Kherson.
Und auch da, ich meine, auch da mussten die, musste die Ukraine richtig für
arbeiten, aber jetzt ist es eher so, ja.
Die umgekehrte Situation ein bisschen wie in wie in Bachmuth,
wo die Russen natürlich auch mit großen Verlusten und Stück für Stück und über
sehr lange Zeit eigentlich noch vorangekommen sind.
Und so wird das wahrscheinlich auch erstmal eine Weile für die Ukrainer jetzt
aussehen, auf absehbare Zeit.
Gut, dann kommen wir doch mal auf die Geschichte mit dem Staudamm.
Also bei der letzten Sendung war der Staudamm gesprengt worden und ich glaube,
das war so zwei, drei Tage danach, dass wir zusammen kamen.
Jetzt zeigt sich eigentlich erst so richtig, was die Auswirkungen davon sind. Also was ist passiert?
Auf einmal ist halt dieser komplette Staudamm, also der wichtige große Staudamm,
der das komplette Dnipro Becken aufgestaut hat, war einfach im Arsch.
Riesige Wassermengen haben sich dann Richtung Schwarzes Meer den Weg gebahnt
an der Stadt Resson vorbei,
von der zwar einiges überflutet wurde, aber die ja weitgehend höher liegt,
also nicht so extrem betroffen ist, aber natürlich im Süden sind sehr viele
Orte überschwemmt worden.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe verschiedene Zahlen gehört, wie viele Leute da jetzt
unmittelbar von betroffen waren.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine fünfstellige Zahl und selbst wenn im Süden natürlich
russisch besetztes Gebiet war,
gab es da ja immer noch Ukrainer, die dort waren und entsprechend jetzt ihre
Häuser verloren haben und gerettet werden mussten und teilweise sind halt auch die Rettungsaktionen,
die die Ukrainer dann eingeleitet haben, noch von Russen beschossen worden und
so weiter. Also es ist alles ganz furchtbar.
Jetzt ist das Wasser aus dem Denibro Becken weitgehend abgelaufen,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also da ist jetzt kein großer Druck mehr, das heißt die Wassermassen ziehen
sich jetzt auch langsam wieder zurück und legen den Blick frei auf die eigentlichen Auswirkungen davon.
Aber vor allem bedeutet das auch, dass das Zypro-Becken jetzt.
Leer gelaufen ist. Das heißt überall da wo nicht der ursprüngliche Flusslauf
ist, da ist das Wasser entweder weg oder es bleiben halt solche Tümpel über.
Je nachdem wie hoch die Gegend da jeweils ist.
Und auf ersten Satellitenbildern sieht man eben, dass da also wirklich riesige
Wattenmeerartige Landschaften auf einmal übrig geblieben sind.
Man sah auch sehr viele Fotos insbesondere an der Küstenlinie von russischen
Seeminen rund um das Kraftwerk, die natürlich dann auch auf einmal sichtbar wurden.
Der ganze theoretische Landebereich im Kraftwerkbereich ist mit Seeminen abgesichert
worden und ja stellt sich natürlich dann auch die Frage was das für militärische
Auswirkungen hat, können wir gleich nochmal drauf kommen.
Aber die eigentliche Frage war ja immer was ist jetzt eigentlich passiert und
wir haben ja da auch drüber spekuliert auch wenn klar war, dass die Nachrichtenlage
zu dem Zeitpunkt noch ein bisschen dünne war.
Im Prinzip haben sich ja so zwei Ideen, standen so ein bisschen im Raum,
nämlich entweder die Russen haben es gesprengt oder die Russen haben es vernachlässigt
und das Ding ist quasi unter seiner eigenen Last zusammengebrochen,
zumal eben der Pegel so hoch angestiegen war, wie schon irgendwie seit Ewigkeiten
nicht oder überhaupt noch nie.
Naja jetzt gab es eine interessante Untersuchung von der New York Times und
die haben halt mit Leuten geredet, die diesen Staudamm sehr gut kennen,
die Pläne sehr gut kennen, also mit Ukrainern die den betrieben haben etc.
Und sich die Gesamtsituation nochmal angeschaut und was so an Satellitenbildern
verfügbar war und sonstigen Fotos.
Was ja am Anfang auch noch so ein bisschen verwirrend war, war dieses wenn er
gesprengt ist, warum hat man dann keine Sprengung gesehen, warum gab es keine
riesigen Feuerwolken etc.
Und das war ja so das was auch so ein bisschen den Nährboden für diese Idee
mit einem Kollaps der Infrastruktur selbst gegeben hat.
Stellt sich raus, dieser Staudamm,
der ist so massiv gebaut und so stark gebaut,
also über die ganze Breite ist das ein extrem tief eingelassener Betonwall,
der 20 Meter hoch ist und an seiner dicksten Stelle 40 Meter dick ist.
So also quasi unten und dann nach oben natürlich immer ein bisschen dünner,
das ist so massiv, dass das sich von außen unmöglich irgendwie sprengen lässt.
Also da hätte die Ukraine mit allem drauf ballern können, was sie in ihrem Arsenal
hätten und das Ding wäre davon nicht
kaputt gegangen. Das war einfach ein unzerstörbarer Bunker. Allerdings.
Gibt es in dieser Struktur einen Gang, einen Maintenance-Gang,
der quasi über die gesamte Länge geht und von der russischen Seite aus begangen
werden kann. Und zwar nur von der russischen Seite aus begangen werden kann.
Und jetzt gilt es eigentlich als sehr wahrscheinlich, dass dort eben von den
Russen Sprengladungen installiert wurden und dann eben auch zu Detonationen gebracht wurden.
Das hat dann eben keine sichtbaren Explosionswolken erzeugt,
weil das eben innerhalb dieses Dams war, der dann einfach quasi durch diese
Sprengung kollabiert ist.
Aber man konnte trotzdem die Detonation, die auf eine Explosion hinweist,
messen. Nämlich an mindestens zwei seismischen Stationen.
Eins davon in der Ukraine und eins davon in Rumänien konnte man relativ klar sehen,
dieses typische seismische Bild, was eben eine Explosion hervorruft,
die man eben von Erdbeben und was auch sonst noch so passiert deutlich unterscheiden kann.
Das heißt, es hat eine Sprengung gegeben und mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
hat die in diesem Passageway stattgefunden.
Man sah auch aus dem All von Satelliten einen Temperaturanstieg,
was auch nochmal auf die Explosion hinweist, also ist es sozusagen klar.
Und vor allem, wenn man sich die Fotos danach anschaut, dann ist halt diese
gesamte Betonstruktur, Also dieses massive Teil auf einem sehr breiten,
also auf dem vollständigen Weg eigentlich weg.
Und das Foto finde ich sagt eigentlich am meisten aus,
weil auf einmal ist sozusagen diese komplette obere Ebene, die jetzt hätte noch
hervorstechen müssen aus dem Wasser, weil die höher gewesen ist als der Pegel
eben jetzt ist, die ist halt einfach komplett weg.
Weg. Und das deutet eben ganz klar darauf hin, dass diese gesamte Betonstruktur
zerstört wurde und dass das eben nur durch eine Sprengung verursacht werden kann.
Ja, und es gibt dann auch Hinweise, dass also kurz nach dieser Sprengung schon
russische Truppen im Süden auch evakuiert wurden.
Am Anfang gab es ja Berichte, die wären ja alle zurückgelassen Das hat sicherlich auch stattgefunden,
aber es gab eben auch schon sehr schnelle Anweisungen, die unmöglich eine Reaktion
auf ein unvorhergesehenes Ereignis haben sein können.
Also das zeigt, dass da eben eine Befehlskette am Start war und dass das eben
schon bewusst gemacht wurde.
Ja, stellt man sich natürlich die Frage, warum?
Warum haben die Russen das jetzt gemacht? Weil ein Nebeneffekt dieser ganzen
Geschichte neben der Überflutung des unteren Flussbereichs ist ja,
Also erstmal die ganzen gegrabenen Verteidigungslinien.
Sind halt überspült worden. Also die Russen haben sozusagen Verteidigungslinien verloren.
Außerdem durch die abgesenkten Pegel ist ja jetzt, das hatten wir ja schon angesprochen,
dieses gesamte Kanalsystem wird jetzt nicht mehr befüllt, weil der Pegel nicht hoch genug ist.
Das heißt es gibt natürlich auch keine Versorgung der Krim mehr mit Wasser aus diesem Kanal.
Es gibt auch keine Versorgung des gesamten südlichen Kresson-Bereichs mehr und
Man kann jetzt davon ausgehen,
dass das in den nächsten Jahren dazu führen wird, dass wieder diese,
so eine Verwüstung dort einsetzt und das einfach Landwirtschaftsanbau dort zumindest
nicht mehr in der alten Form möglich ist und unter Umständen halt auch überhaupt
nicht mehr bis ein neuer Staudamm gebaut ist und das sozusagen alles wieder
von vorne losgehen kann.
Aber für die Russen ist es halt auch erstmal ein riesiger Verlust,
weil die Krim erhält nun mal ihr Trinkwasser im Wesentlichen aus dieser Quelle
und auch auf der Krim war es nicht so,
dass dort überall blühende Landschaften waren und dass es sozusagen so ein Ort
der umfangreichen Anbauflächen war.
Das galt eigentlich nur für so diesen südöstlichen Bereich.
Dort ist es eben aus geologischen Gründen schon immer gut gewesen, was anzubauen.
Aber der nördliche Krimtal ist eben auch nur durch diese Bewässerung dieses
Kanals in so fruchtbares Land überführt worden.
Und das wird natürlich jetzt alles wegfallen. Also auch in der Krim wird es
einen starken Einbruch der landwirtschaftlichen Produktion geben.
Jetzt ganz unabhängig von den unmittelbaren Auswirkungen des Krieges,
die mittelbaren Auswirkungen dann halt langfristig so oder so zu sehen.
Ja und aus russischer Sicht, ich meine, dass das etwas pervers erscheinend ist.
Und dass ja dieses ganze Gebiet eigentlich offiziell Teil von Russland ist oder
der russischen Föderation, also aus russischer Sicht zumindest.
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, warum zerstören sie jetzt dort quasi ihr eigenes Gebiet.
Aber wie wir dann ja auch gesehen haben bei anderen Ereignissen ist,
dass letztlich den Russen die Provinz eher egal ist.
Also Moskau zählt und alles andere ist so ein bisschen verzichtbar oder zumindest
gibt man in Moskau nicht so viel darauf,
wenn dann in Belgorod oder sonst wo da fremde Truppen einmarschieren oder so.
Also so wichtig scheinen die Provinzen dann nicht zu sein, egal ob das jetzt
irgendwie Ukraine oder Ex-Ukraine oder offiziell Russland ist.
Also zumindest kurzfristig nicht und natürlich sind ihnen die landwirtschaftlichen
Ressourcen auch etwas wert, aber ob die dann erst in 10 Jahren wieder aktiviert
werden können ist ihnen eigentlich egal.
Erstmal haben, alles kaputt machen und vor allem ist es ja auch so ein Nebeneffekt,
das vertreibt ja dann quasi potenziell auch Ukrainer die dort nicht mehr leben
können, weil quasi ihre Lebensgrundlage genommen wurde und dann wird das halt
dadurch auch alles entvölkert und kann dann später russifiziert werden.
Also das ist ja so ein bisschen eine böse Logik, die noch mit dazukommt.
Steckt wahrscheinlich ja ein Stück weit,
auch mit dahinter, diese Denke. Was auch nicht ganz auszuschließen ist,
immer noch, dass da schon vielleicht auch möglicherweise die Befehlskette versagt hat,
dass also die Sprengung nicht unbedingt jetzt von oben angeordnet worden sein muss,
Sondern die Truppen halt,
oder die Kommandeure dort einfach bestimmte Vorgaben hatten.
Wann dieser Damm zu sprengen ist und ja,
dass Leute gedacht haben einfach,
okay, das ist jetzt die, die, die Ukrainer
kommen jetzt und die Bedingungen sind erfüllt und
deswegen machen wir das jetzt
bis hin zu ja was auch immer noch nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
ist ist ja irgendein technisches
Versagen dass die Sprengsätze die
sie dort wie gesagt ist ziemlich sicher
platziert hatten ja durch
ja technisches Versagen
oder wie auch immer gesprengt wurden das
lässt sich auch noch nicht vollkommen ausschließen würde
ich würde ich sagen weil so richtig
weil weil bisher hat sich ja auch keine seite so richtig dazu
bekannt und es scheint
auch gewesen so gewesen zu sein also
zumindest strelkov russischer blogger sagt das auch in der letzten sendung das
oder weiß ich nicht dass beide seiten so ein bisschen überrascht gewesen sein von dem von dem Ganzen.
Aber nach wie vor unabhängig davon, es war russischer Sprengstoff,
der den Damm zum Versagen gebracht hat.
Das ist sehr sehr wahrscheinlich und wie jetzt genau die Umstände und Befehlskette
gewesen ist bei der Sprengung.
Das lässt sich noch nicht mit Sicherheit sagen. A.
Und es ist am Ende auch egal. Also es ist auf jeden Fall klar,
die Russen waren schuld und von daher ist das einfach eine weitere riesige Tragödie,
die dieser Krieg zu den sonstigen riesigen Tragödien noch hinzugefügt hat.
Hat und das müssen sie sich auf jeden Fall auch als ganz, ganz,
ganz großes Kriegsverbrechen, in dem diese ganze Geschichte jetzt ja nicht arm
ist, noch mal ankreien lassen.
Und worüber jetzt auch schon,
vielfach spekuliert wird, dadurch, dass jetzt das Reservoir weg ist,
es aber noch vier andere Reservoirs flussaufwärts gibt,
haben die Ukrainer zumindest die Möglichkeit, für eine Zeit lang,
für ein paar Wochen, das Wasser komplett abzudrehen, was da durchläuft.
Und, wir sagen auch noch, den Rest vielleicht nicht ganz, aber schon extrem trocken zu legen.
Das Ganze und so daneben auch ganz neue Möglichkeiten und ganz neue Angriffswege zu schaffen.
Aber bisher scheint es so zu sein, dass tendenziell eher die Russen davon.
Leicht profitiert haben, weil sie wohl die Reserven aus dem Hinterland tatsächlich
in die Nähe der aktiven Front, also mehr Richtung Osten, verlegt haben.
Kurzfristig auf jeden Fall scheint es irgendwie leichte Vorteile erst mal zu geben,
aber wir auch schon beim letzten Mal gesagt haben,
dass es ist Sommer, das Wasser fließt relativ schnell ab und es ist warm und
es wird wahrscheinlich schneller austrocknen, so als viele das denken.
Und wir haben ja schon gesehen, wir haben ja vorhin auch gesagt,
wir haben dieser Brückenkopf auf der… A.S.
Südlich der Eindhorn-Australie-Brücke.
B. Ja, genau, bei Oleschki,
da konnte man ganz gut sehen, dass die vorgelagerten Straßen mittlerweile schon
wieder befahrbar sind und dass dort bereits Kampfhandlungen mit auch gepanzerten
Kettenfahrzeugen stattgefunden,
haben.
Ja also muss man sehen natürlich ist dieser
ganze Boden der da jetzt ist nach wie vor durchdrängend und weich da kannst
du jetzt nicht mal eben mit nem Panzer rüberfahren also das wird so natürlich
nicht stattfinden aber die Ukrainer werden Teufel tun und diese Gelegenheit
nicht in irgendeiner Form auch für sich zu nutzen wissen.
Also da bieten sich vielleicht trickreiche Möglichkeiten mit irgendwelchen anderen
Fahrzeugen rüber zu fahren oder irgendwelchen ferngesteuerten Geräten oder keine
Ahnung, was auch immer, Infanterie.
Also das kann es teilweise auch leichter machen.
Und was wohl auch alles für die Russen dann jetzt schwieriger macht,
ist, dass die Ukrainer eben das Ganze auch mit Artillerie von der Kershan-Seite
aus unterstützen können, ihre angelandeten Bodentruppen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch hilfreich
oder macht es eben auch zu einem größeren Problem für die Russen.
Watch this space sag ich nur. Gut kommen wir zu dem eigentlichen großen Aufreger der letzten Tage.
Das kam, naja, weiß ich nicht,
ob es unerwartet kam, aber auf jeden Fall hatte es dann eine Menge Überraschungspotenzial,
nämlich der eskalierende Konflikt zwischen den Wagner-Truppen auf der einen
Seite und dem russischen Staat bzw.
Dem Verteidigungsministerium auf der anderen Seite.
Und dem anschließenden Marsch auf Moskau.
Das Ganze fing ja damit an, dass Shoigu,
der Verteidigungsminister, einen Erlass rausgegeben hat, der die Eingliederung
der sogenannten freiwilligen Armeen in das russische Armeesystem zum 1. Juli angeordnet hat.
Mit Freiwilligen meinen die halt auch die ganzen PMCs, also die ganzen privaten Armeen,
wovon Wagner natürlich die sichtbarste, größte und bekannteste ist,
aber es gab auch noch ein paar andere, da gehören im Prinzip auch die Achmat-Truppen
von diesem verrückten Tschetschenen Kadirov dazu.
Und ja, es war halt so ein Erlass, der gesagt hat, alle Söldner,
die in diesen Truppen organisiert sind, sollen halt bis zum 20.
Juni Verträge mit der russischen Föderation unterschreiben, wie die genau gestaltet sind.
Keine Ahnung. Und alle Gruppen, die das nicht befolgen werden, würden vom 1.
Juli an von der Versorgung abgeschnitten. Das war so ein bisschen die Aussage.
Und während halt die meisten da mitgemacht haben,
also auch Kadirov mit seinem Ahmad hat das halt irgendwie gemacht,
der ist ja eh so ein Putin-Buddy und weiß ja gar ja wie gesagt,
was da jetzt letzten Endes wirklich der Vertrag war oder was dieser Vertrag
auch nur irgendwie fährt ist mit dem was da steht, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Tatsache war, dass Prigoshin, der nun schon seit Wochen rumpoltert und sich da eine Konfrontation,
eine mediale Konfrontation mit Putin, dem Staat und insbesondere eben mit Schoigu
da liefert, der war halt not amused.
Und das hat sich sicherlich auch intern schon länger abgezeichnet.
Also es war einfach klar, dass es hier in irgendeiner Form nochmal zu einem
Konflikt kommen würde. Und der wurde damit jetzt eben eingeleitet bzw. eskaliert.
Und Prigoshin, wie er eben so drauf ist, hat dann auch erst mal einen eigenen
Vertrag vorgelegt, der irgendwie besagt, dass das russische Verteidigungsministerium
dann Wagner beitreten soll. Also guter Witz, ne?
Konkret standen da so Dinge drin, wie dass Wagner
irgendwie direkt im Verteidigungsministerium auch vertreten ist und mit Sprache
Rechte hat bei allen Aktionen und an allen Planungen zu beteiligen ist und so.
Ja, insofern kann man sagen, dass Wagner quasi als gleichberechtigter Partner
und als gleichberechtigter, autonomer Partner weiter existiert.
Und vielleicht noch so ein paar Worte generell zu Wagner,
also Wagner dürfte ja schon die größte Privatarmee der Welt sein,
die auch mit den schwersten Waffen ausgestattet ist.
Also die dann eben auch eigene Artillerie und schwere Kampfpanzer und sogar
auch teilweise eigene Kampfflugzeuge und Kampfpiloten und so weiter hat.
Also das alleine schon ist halt massiv.
Und zu Spitzenzeiten hatten sie ja 50.000.
Soldaten unter Vertrag. Aktuell
sollten es noch so zwischen 20.000 und 25.000 irgendwo gewesen sein.
Der Rest ist dann entweder gefallen oder dann entlassen worden nach sechs Jahren.
Also gerade von den ganzen Sträflingen, die da aus den Gefängnissen kamen,
soll ungefähr die Hälfte überlebt haben.
Und davon hat der Großteil wohl jetzt auch seine sechs Monate um und ist tatsächlich
dann auch freigekommen.
Was auch teilweise nicht für allzu viel Begeisterung jetzt bei normalen Russen geführt hat,
dass dort jetzt diese ganzen Ex-Mörder mit sechs Monaten davon gekommen sind
und jetzt wieder frei sich in der Gesellschaft bewegen können.
So, das fand ich gut.
Ansonsten werde ich noch...
Wagner ist einfach anders, also ich würde das vielleicht so beschrieben,
dass Wagner mehr, ja es ist eine Privatfirma, würde ich sagen,
fast wie so ein Start-up mit so ein bisschen Start-up-Mentalität,
während die russische Armee eben, ja, so ein alter, verkrusteter Staatsbetrieb ist.
Ist und die sollten dann jetzt irgendwo zusammenarbeiten und da gab es dann
natürlich schon auch jede menge kulturelle Clashes einfach,
weil natürlich Wagner durchaus so ein bisschen auch Rosinenpicken spielen konnte
und Wagner glaube ich auch sehr aggressiv war so beim Beschaffen von Waffen und Material.
Der hat halt einfach mit allen Mitteln gearbeitet und es geht auch nicht anders.
Also von irgendwie Bestechung, indem er da ja im Militär dann eben entsprechend
Leute auch geschmiert hat, dass sie, dass sie da mehr Waffen in seine Richtung
umleiten über ja Bedrohungen.
Also teilweise haben sie auch dann von der russischen Armee auch Material einfach
den abgenommen so mit mit Gewalt also mit mit mit Raub und und anderen Dingen und sind halt.
All dem irgendwo durchgekommen.
Und das hat es ihnen dann auch mit ermöglicht, diese Erfolge zu haben,
weil sie einfach sich auch sehr flexibel anpassen konnten,
viele taktische Innovationen hatten,
ihre eigene Logistik teilweise dann auch mit aufgebaut hatten,
als es dann zu Engpässen kam und so und ja,
im Grunde genommen konnte sich dann eben auch auf diese Art und Weise Prigoshin
ja wirklich profilieren und es gibt so Schätzungen,
dass ungefähr die Wagner so
150 Millionen ungefähr an.
Sold pro Monat ausgezahlt
hat an seine Kämpfer und das insgesamt so wohl zwischen 250 und 350 Millionen
pro Monat der Betrieb von Wagner gekostet hat jetzt mit all den Waffen und Sprit
und Munition und allem drum und dran,
also nur um mal so die Größenordnungen mal genannt zu haben,
ja, und das alles sollte jetzt aufgelöst werden und Frigoschin hatte halt dann
Zeta und Mordio geschrien,
auch weil wohl der Plan war, dass Wagner die Einheiten,
wo ja jetzt eine gewisse Kohärenz auch entstanden ist,
die zusammen im Kampf waren, viele davon auch Profis oder die halt auch auf
eine bestimmte Art und Weise miteinander zu kämpfen gelernt haben,
dass das im Prinzip alles zerstört werden sollte.
Also dass die Leute dann bei der Armee unterschreiben,
aber dann eben nicht als Wagner oder als,
keine Ahnung, als das Wagner-Bataillon oder wie auch immer der russischen Armee
jetzt zusammenbleibt, sondern dass sie eben verteilt werden sollten und seine Befürchtung,
Was er auch gesagt hat und deshalb die Leute dann auch mitgemacht haben,
dass dann befürchtet wurde, dass seine erfahrenen und qualifizierten Kommandeure
dann als Fußvolk in der Armee verheizt werden.
Dass sie eben auch rangmäßig nicht entsprechend eingestuft werden,
weil sie eben keinen offiziellen Rang haben
und sah das eben als riesige Verschwendung an Kampfkraft und Zerstörung irgendwie der einzigen Einheit,
die im letzten Jahr irgendwelche signifikanten Erfolge erzielt hat.
Das ist zumindest die Motivation, die er so zum Besten gegeben hat.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich alles ist an Motivation oder vielleicht
sogar noch nicht mal die Hauptmotivation.
Aber so erklärt sich zumindest, ich sag mal,
warum die Leute keinen Bock hatten, jetzt bei der russischen Armee zu unterschreiben
und dann lieber riskiert haben, dann, ja, mit Prygogine diesen Aufstand zu inszenieren.
Und ja, es wurde viel auch von einem Putsch gesprochen,
wobei ja gleich am Anfang auch viel, dass das irgendwie für einen Putsch,
dass das nicht aussieht wie ein klassischer Putsch, klassischen Putsch.
So versuchst du halt, ja, Rundfunksender und
den Sitz der Regierung und Verteidigungsministerium und so schnell zu besetzen
und Schlüsselpersonal festzusetzen oder unter deine Kontrolle zu bringen und
all All das ist nicht passiert,
sondern was wir eben gesehen haben, waren zwei große Kolonnen,
die sich auf den Weg gemacht haben, die eine Richtung Moskau und die andere Richtung Berlin.
Richtung Rostov am Don.
Und ja, das war eben, das war so ein bisschen plötzlich die Ausgangslage und
eigentlich so ein klassischer,
ich sag mal, Militäraufstand oder Söldneraufstand,
Und der, ja, den es historisch immer wieder gegeben hat, wo du einfach Truppen
hast und dann brauchst du die nicht mehr oder zahlst nicht mehr oder hast keine Kohle mehr.
Und dann fühlen sich die Truppen ungerecht behandelt und haben halt Waffen und
machen dann eben entsprechenden Protest.
Konnte das ganze was dann passiert ist auch so ein bisschen mehr als ich sag
mal bewaffnete Demo bezeichnen oder auch als Show of Force.
Genau, denn was denn das jetzt letzten Endes war, darüber ging dann die Meinung
auch auseinander und es wurde halt zunächst einmal von einem Coup berichtet,
sprich der Versuch, dass das ein Versuch sein könnte, die russische Staatsregierung zu übernehmen.
Marsch auf Moskau und das ging ja dann auch relativ schnell.
Also Rostov am Don, das war die erste Stadt die eingenommen wurde und das war
halt auch weitgehend kampflos.
Mit anderen Worten, die sind da einfach rein, haben gesagt, guten Tag,
wir sind's, Wagner, ihr lasst mal hier schön die Waffen stecken, das gehört jetzt uns.
Und man kann schon mal drüber mutmaßen, warum denn das überhaupt kampflos schon
dort ging, dass man so eine Millionenstadt mal so eben militärisch übernehmen
kann. Es wurden dann auch relativ schnell die Flugfelder gesichert.
Ein Trupp ist dann irgendwie auch südlich nach Richtung Krasnodar marschiert
und von dort ging es dann nach Voronezh in den Norden und das ist halt insofern interessant,
dass sowohl Rostov als auch Voronezh sind halt ganz ganz wichtige logistische
Hubs für diesen Krieg gegen die Ukraine.
Also da geht wirklich ein Großteil des Materials durch,
dort liegen die Logistikzentralen auf russischem Gebiet und das lag dann eben auch mal brach,
also da gab es dann irgendwie keinen logistischen Nachschub mehr für den Krieg,
weil sich das auf einmal nicht mehr unter Kontrolle des russischen Militärs befand.
Und nicht nur das, sondern es waren dann auf einmal 400 Fahrzeuge auf dem Weg
Richtung Moskau und dort ging dann die Panik gleich so richtig los.
Da wurden dann erstmal die Autobahnen nach Süden, so 50 Kilometer vor Moskau,
wurden dann erstmal aufgebaggert.
Es wurden dann an verschiedenen Stellen Laster mit Sand beladen und mitten auf die Straße gestellt.
Das hat dann nicht besonders viel gewirkt. Die wurden dann von den Wagenreiz
dann auch einfach mal zur Seite geschoben, nicht ganz klar mit welcher Gewalteinwendung,
aber offensichtlich haben sie sich davon nicht groß aufhalten lassen.
Und vor allem waren sie sehr schnell unterwegs, was sie wohl auch dadurch abgesichert haben,
dass sie quasi gut logistisch organisiert waren,
also der ganze Sprit den sie brauchten, den haben sie irgendwie schon vorher
bei den Tankstellen eingekauft,
viele Fahrzeuge schnell unterwegs und was dann den Russen besonders Ärger gemacht hat,
also dem russischen Verteidigungsministerium, war, dass es jetzt nicht einfach nur,
was weiß ich, PKWs und Laster waren mit denen die da unterwegs waren,
sondern da gehört ein Panzer, ein anderes Militärgerät, also ein richtig schweres
Gerät dazu und auch mobile Flugabwehrsysteme.
Und ja dann kam das Verteidigungsministerium auf die Idee da doch mal was gegen
zu tun und hat dann eben Hubschrauber und andere Flugzeuge in den Einsatz gebracht,
die dann halt von den Wagners einfach abgeschossen wurden.
Also ich glaube im Zuge dieses ganzen Marsches sind so sieben oder acht verschiedene
Fluggeräte vom Himmel geholt worden, vor allem Hubschrauber.
Und das heißt ja eben nicht nur Hubschrauber, sondern auch Hubschrauber-Piloten,
davon haben wir jetzt auch nicht so viel. Und um das alles noch zu toppen,
ging dann auch noch ein anderes Flugzeug verloren. Das hast du dir angeschaut.
Ja, also bei dem Flugzeug, was abgeschossen wurde, handelte es sich um eine
Relais-Station, um so einen mobilen, luftmobilen Kommando-Punkt.
Also im Prinzip ein Flugzeug, was mit sehr vielen Funkgeräten ausgestattet ist und in Lage ist,
dann direkt mit den Bataillonen zu kommunizieren,
direkt mit den Truppen am Boden zu kommunizieren und dann auch als Relais-Station gilt,
also kann halt dann eben auch quasi Funkverbindung mit Moskau halten,
sodass halt jemand in Moskau oder sonst wo in Russland dann einfach direkt mit
den Truppen in der Gegend kommunizieren kann.
Und meistens sitzt dann auch noch ein General oder sowas mit an Bord,
der dann auch direkt dort Befehle geben kann.
Also im Prinzip war das ein fliegender Befehlsstand und Relaiszentrale und eine
fliegende Telefonanlage, wenn man so will, ja.
Fliegender Bündelfunk. Und da waren wohl alleine neun oder zehn Besatzungsmitglieder
an Bord, die da die ganze Technik bedient haben.
Und ja, das hat dann wohl auch...
Das ist ja nicht so Personal, was du mal eben beim Arbeitsamt kriegst, ne?
A. Und das hat wohl dann auch ein bisschen zu Zerwürfnissen geführt,
also das haben ihm im Militär einige auch übel genommen, weil das Ding war ja
auch, oder Prigojin, muss ich mir auch vorstellen. Der hat ja jetzt...
Ja, nicht nur ein Jahr, sondern seit der Gründung von Wagner,
das ist glaube ich vor zehn Jahren ist es, haben sie ja in aller Welt,
in allen Krisengebieten mit der Armee zusammen gekämpft und auch in erster Linie
Aufträge dann wahrscheinlich auch vom Geheimdienst,
vom FSB bekommen und entsprechend Informationen.
Das heißt Prigogine und auch teilweise seine Kommandeure,
die ja auch wiederum Ex-Soldaten waren,
also auch der andere, der eigentliche Gründer von Wagner, ist ja ein Veteran
aus dem Tschetschenien, aus den Tschetschenien-Kriegen.
Ziemlich, Ja, so ein Neonazi wie aus einem Hollywood-Film mit SS-Runen auftätowiert
und ich glaube ein Hakenkreuz hat er irgendwo auch, ja.
Und nur sagen, es gab eben, kann man davon ausgehen, sehr viele auch persönliche
Verbindungen in die Armee und auch dann verschiedene Freundschaften und Partnerschaften, weshalb.
Prigogine auch so ein bisschen davon ausgegangen ist,
dass sich ihm halt die Armee-Einheiten auch anschließen werden und dass die
Armee mit teilnehmen wird an seinem Marsch.
Das ist nur sehr begrenzt passiert.
Es gab dann wohl einige Einheiten, die sich ihm unterstellt hatten.
Unter anderem eben auch eine, die für Luftabwehr mit zuständig war.
Also ich glaube, es war nicht alleine nur die mobile Flugabwehr,
sondern es gab dann eben auch tatsächlich Flugabwehrstellungen der regulären
Armee, die ihm beim Abschuss geholfen haben.
Aber eben andere nicht und gerade so einige seiner Freunde in der Armee und
gerade in der Luftwaffe waren halt ziemlich pisst darüber,
dass er dann die Hubschrauber abgeschossen hat.
Und da drohte wohl dann auch wiederum innerhalb von Wagner so eine gewisse Meuterei, sag ich mal.
Also da gab es dann auch innerhalb von Wagner so gewisse Risse,
weil die einen wollten dann auch weiter nach Moskau und wollten einfach Blut
sehen und die anderen, ja, andere waren halt nicht so begeistert.
Aber Fakt ist, dass in dem Moment einfach, ja, Prigogine Putin im Grunde genommen
richtig bei den Eiern hatte.
Zwar war es sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass er jetzt irgendwie Putin oder,
was weiß ich, Moskau komplett besetzen oder die Regierung übernehmen könnte, davon ging man jetzt,
ging die meisten nicht aus, weil es gab jetzt, dazu hätte halt massiv auch,
dass das Militär komplett zu ihm überlaufen müssen,
aber die viele Einheiten haben sich halt eher so verhalten,
naja gut, okay, wir kämpfen jetzt nicht gegen euch,
wir lassen dich jetzt durch, aber wir kommen jetzt auch nicht mit nach Moskau,
also da gab es nur eher wenige, die sich jetzt tatsächlich angeschlossen haben,
aber Er hat vorhin schon gesagt, dass er dann auch Rostov-am-Don praktisch komplett übernommen hat.
Auch dort die ganzen Flughäfen, von denen viele Einsätze aus in Richtung Ukraine geflogen werden,
die hatte er dann auch übernommen, hat aber wohl angeblich den laufenden Betrieb
nicht behindert oder nicht unterbunden.
Muss man auch mit Vorsicht genießen, aber was wohl wahr ist,
dass jeder Hubschrauber, der abgehoben hat,
dann jemanden von Wagner mit an Bord haben musste, um sicherzustellen,
dass diese Hubschrauber, die da in der Gegend von Rostov abheben,
nicht gegen Wagner eingesetzt werden.
Aber keine Ahnung, was sie mit den Kampfflugzeugen gemacht haben,
weil da sind ja viele Einsitzige dabei.
Da kann man jetzt niemanden mitschicken. Also ich denke schon,
dass im Endeffekt durchaus eine gewisse Störung eingetreten ist,
aber nicht in nennenswertem Ausmaß.
Aber wenn Prigozhin jetzt gewollt hätte, so hätte er quasi komplett den Truppen
in der Ukraine 80 bis 90 Prozent des Nachschubs.
Schneiden können oder einstellen können. Plus, dass natürlich ein anderes Problem
oder Dilemma wahrscheinlich gewesen wäre,
dass er das gar nicht hätte machen müssen, sondern wahrscheinlich von Moskau
aus der Nachschub eingestellt worden wäre,
weil man ansonsten ja Nachschub zu ihm geschickt hätte und er sich als erstes
an dem Nachschub hätte bedienen können und seine Truppen.
Das heißt, es kann eben auch gut sein, dass alleine deswegen,
sagen wir von Moskaus Seite aus, jetzt Züge gestoppt worden sind,
weil du würdest jetzt nicht ihm noch zusätzlich Material und Panzer da runterschicken. A.
Zumal ja dann auch die Verteidigung von Moskau auch anstand und dort eben auch
nicht sehr viele Truppen waren.
Also es gab jetzt in Moskau nicht so ohne weiteres schweres Gerät,
was so platziert werden konnte. Es gab zwar ein paar Absperrungen etc.
Aber das war alles so eher mittelschwerm Gerät.
Also die ganzen Panzer sind an der Front und im Prinzip ist Russland nach innen ein bisschen offen.
Wobei alle davon ausgehen, das Problem war, dass das so schnell und überraschend
gekommen ist. Was auch so ein bisschen irre ist, weil angeblich die CIA wusste
Bescheid, dass das kommen wird.
Aber entweder der FSB wusste nicht Bescheid oder er wusste Bescheid,
aber hat es vorgezogen, das Verteidigungsministerium und Putin nicht davon zu
informieren, dass das kommen wird.
So ist auch noch so ein interessantes Detail.
Aber dadurch, dass das Ganze jetzt so schnell ging und er auch wirklich einen
Rekord-Marschtempo hingelegt hat,
was eben dadurch möglich war,
dass alles auf Radfahrzeuge und Radlader,
auch die schweren Panzer wurden eben dann auf LKW gepackt und zusätzlich eben
auch Munition und Sprit haben sie auch mitgeführt in größerer Zahl und ja,
sind dann mit relativ hoher Marschgeschwindigkeit in Kolonne Richtung Moskau
und mussten wohl auch nicht allzu viel anhalten unterwegs,
beziehungsweise an den Checkpoints wurden sie durchgelassen,
auch weil klar war, dass an den Checkpoints in der kurzen Zeit nicht genug.
Kampfkraft versammelt werden konnte, um ihn jetzt wirklich aufzuhalten.
Und teilweise waren auch diese Checkpoints ganz intelligent auf der Autobahn
platziert, während halt die Raststätte nebenbei frei war.
Und dann sind sie einfach über die Raststätte gefahren, zum Beispiel an einer Stelle.
Und haben die links liegen lassen.
Einfach ja Jetzt ist natürlich die frage was was wollte
brigogine jetzt eigentlich damit wirklich bezwecken
und Hat er sich da verzockt weil den eindruck macht es natürlich jetzt so ein
bisschen die öffentlich geäußerten forderungen waren halt auf der einen seite
ja hier scheuge und gerasimov die sind ja inkompetent die müssen jetzt unbedingt
abgesetzt werden weil sonst geht hier der krieg in der ukraine nicht voran Und
da ist sicherlich auch irgendwas dran.
Aber natürlich ging es ihm vor allem darum, dass eben Wagner überlebt.
Und das scheint ihm nicht so richtig gelungen zu sein.
Es gab dann Verhandlungen.
Also in Russland ist dann auch alles irgendwie auf Anti-Wagner umgeschaltet worden.
Also man muss ja vielleicht noch ein Stück zurückgehen und was sagen,
also Putins Reaktion, also bemerkenswert war, ich meine Prigogine ist zwar auch
durchaus Putin angegangen, aber eigentlich nicht direkt.
Also eigentlich, ja, hat er sich eben vor allen Dingen auf Schoigu und Gerasimov
eingeschossen und wollte,
dass die weggehen und hatte vielleicht auch die Hoffnung,
dass Putin sich auf seine Seite schlägt oder so,
aber was halt passiert ist,
ich meine jetzt, ich glaube, das ging irgendwie abends,
ging das los, wenn ich das richtig sehe, und
sie sind über Nacht dann Richtung Moskau
gefahren und Putin hat sich dann am nächsten Morgen das erste Mal öffentlich
geäußert in einer ziemlich chaotischen Rede oder in einer sehr unrussischen Rede oder einer Rede,
die insofern skurril war.
Putin dort quasi die Armee und das Volk angebettelt hat, doch ihn und Moskau zu beschützen.
Und das ist halt nicht irgendwie, wie der große Führer jetzt eigentlich in Russland
aufzutreten hat, sondern der große Führer hat hier, ja, alles wird gut.
Ich bin hier in Kontrolle und ich bin am Hebel und macht euch keine Sorgen,
tut einfach, was ich sage und alles wird gut.
Und dieser Verräter, Prigogine, der kann ja alles verzeihen, aber nur verrat nicht.
Und also eine Rede, wo man merkte,
dass Putin nicht on top of his game gerade ist,
sondern sich einfach mehr oder weniger als Angsthase geriert hat an der Stelle.
Und dann eben auch gleichzeitig geschworen, dass alle jetzt zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden,
nur um dann, ja, wie wir alle wissen,
ein paar Stunden später am Nachmittag dann plötzlich einen Deal zu verkünden,
in dem jetzt doch niemand zur Rechenschaft gezogen wird.
Und was jetzt die Ziele angeht, was du meinst? Ja, ich meine einerseits gab
es halt Ziele, die Wagner eben offen formuliert hat und die die auf der Hand
liegen, nämlich sagen...
Existenz von Wagner weiter zu sichern, mit eben den Argumenten,
ja, einzige kampfkräftige Truppe in Russland, wobei ich das auch für stark übertrieben halte.
Also es ist halt anders.
Sie kann halt andere Dinge als die russische Armee. Aber die russische Armee
kann Dinge, die sowas wie Wagner nicht kann.
Es ist jetzt auch nicht.
Die super Special Forces Einheit, sondern wenn die auf professionelle Soldaten
oder professionelle gut ausgerüstete Einheiten gestoßen sind in der Vergangenheit
In Syrien haben die Amerikaner irgendwie den Boden mit denen gewischt.
Die Amerikaner haben einfach innerhalb von mehreren Stunden in Syrien,
ja, hat halt Wagner plus irgendwelche syrischen Truppen mal probiert,
was passiert, wenn sie denn eine von den Amerikanern geschützte.
Ölförderanlage und Raffinerie angreifen und wurden dann eben komplett kurz und klein gebombt.
In der Wikipedia gibt es irgendwie fünf verschiedene Varianten,
was wirklich passiert ist und ob jetzt zwischen 10 und 250 Toten auf Wagner
und Syrisch- und Assad-Truppen,
Seite, je nachdem, was man liest, aber Fakt ist,
dass das irgendwie so ein Trutanschießen war letztlich und sie den Amerikanern
nichts entgegenzusetzen hatten.
Insofern ist das jetzt auch keine Wundereinheit, sondern wie gesagt,
Startup auf der einen Seite, Startups können manche Sachen besser und andere
Sachen gar nicht, Da brauchst du halt ein Großkonzern, wie eine komplette Armee, um diese Dinge zu tun.
Trotzdem sind sie natürlich irgendwie gefährlich und vor allem in dieser Situation,
wo sie diesen Aufstand gemacht haben und alle von Q geredet haben,
ist auf jeden Fall da einigen in Moskau so ein bisschen they lost it so.
Also da hat sich eine gewisse Panik breitgemacht, nicht nur beim Militär,
sondern eben auch in der ganzen Elite, weil die jetzt gedacht haben,
jetzt kommt hier irgendwie Wagner und haut uns alle weg und nimmt unsere Willen im Tessin weg, ne?
Ja, die haben nicht nur gezuckt, sondern die haben sich wirklich in die Hosen gemacht.
Also ja, und muss tatsächlich sagen, die Situation war brenzlig und hätte durchaus
auch zu einem, in einem Bürgerkrieg eskalieren können, wenn das anders gelaufen wäre.
Wenn Prigogine gewollt hätte, dann, also es lag eher in Prigogines Hand einen
richtigen Bürgerkrieg anzuzetteln.
Trotzdem hat sich Putin dagegen entschieden oder dafür entschieden voll gegenzuhalten,
also mit seinen Mitteln, die er meinte zu haben,
also sofort wurde irgendwie Wagner in den Medien weggeschwiegen,
alle Plakate wurden von den Straßen entfernt und jegliche Rekrutierungsbemühungen
von Wagner wurden gestoppt, der frisch eröffnete Bürokomplex in so einem Tower
in Sankt Petersburg wurde geschlossen.
Also sofort war Wagner von nützlichen Idioten auf Staatsfeind umgemünzt worden
und alle warten jetzt gespannt darauf was passiert und ja was passierte dann auf einmal,
stoppte diese Kolonne und fuhr nicht weiter auf Moskau fort,
sondern ruf sie auch nicht ein, sondern zog sich dann aus Rostow und aus all
diesen ganzen Orten, die sie innerhalb von 24 Stunden eingenommen haben,
den ganzen Flughäfen zurück und verschwand wieder irgendwo hin.
Ich weiß gar nicht wohin. Sind sie eigentlich wieder auf das Gebiet der Ukraine
zurück? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
In Lager, also wir hatten wohl irgendwelche zugewiesenen Lager,
in denen sie ausharren sollten, bis sie dann halt ihr Material abgeben und sich dann auflösen.
Auf jeden Fall wurde dann bekannt, dass es wohl einen Vermittlungsversuch,
einen erfolgreichen gegeben hat,
in dem auch der belarussische Diktator Lukaschenko involviert war,
der halt sowohl Putin natürlich gut kennt und mit ihm gut buddy ist,
die es aber eben auch Prigogine schon seit 20 Jahren kennt.
Und der hat, tja, irgendwie rausgehandelt, dass der Vorstoß abgeblasen wird,
wie auch immer er das gemacht hat.
Und es gab irgendeine Form von Deal, der dann darin resultierte,
dass zumindest für alle an diesem Aufstand Beteiligten Straffreiheit herrschte,
einschließlich Prigogine selber, die sich aber eben zurückziehen und Pryogen
angeblich irgendwie nach Belarus abgeschoben werden sollte,
wo er jetzt vielleicht tatsächlich auch ist oder auch nicht,
das ist gerade von der Nachrichtenlage her noch ein bisschen unklar.
Tja, und jetzt ist natürlich auch unklar, wie es hier überhaupt weitergeht.
So, also einerseits ist unklar, wie geht es mit Wagner weiter.
Also irgendwie zeichnet sich jetzt ab, dass es sein könnte, dass Wagner als
Organisation aufgelöst wird.
Zumindest auf russischem Boden.
Ja, es gab wohl erste Signale, dass aber Wagner irgendwie weiter im Ausland tätig sein soll.
Ich meine, dort hat halt Wagner in diversen Ländern,
sind sie für die Sicherheit von Ja,
Minen- und Ölfördereinrichtungen und so zuständig,
wo sie ordentlich Kasse machen, wo sie dann halt mitverdienen so und sich letztlich
rausfinanzieren und der Teil soll wohl bleiben,
dann sind sie nach wie vor, ich meine in Syrien wohl nicht unwichtig.
Also so ganz einfach mit, sagen wir mal,
von einem Tag auf den anderen Schluss machen ist wahrscheinlich nicht oder komplett
dicht machen ist schwierig im Moment in der Praxis oder schwieriger,
als man sich das so gedacht hat.
Das ist die eine Sache, aber ansonsten scheint es wohl so zu sein,
dass Wagner, zumindest die Truppen,
die da jetzt in, also das Letzte,
was ich jetzt gelesen hatte, war, dass Putin gesagt haben soll,
dass die Wagner-Leute die Wahl haben,
jetzt entweder sich der russischen Armee einzugliedern, so zu unterstellen und
dann quasi dort zu unterschreiben, oder mit Prigogine nach Belarus zu gehen.
Oder nach Hause. Ja, das Nachhause wurde interessanterweise nicht erwähnt.
Ja, also sozusagen was anderes machen, was mit Holz oder so.
Ja, also der Deal scheint zu sein, oder das momentane Angebot scheint zu sein
an die Wagner-Leute, so auch Armee oder Exil. Ja, also von...
Zuhause dann friedlich sich zur Ruhe.
Aber das heißt ja dann auch, dass es Wagner auf russischem Territorium nicht mehr gibt.
Ja. Und dann könnte halt der Quick Fix sein, dass es das auf belarussischem Gebiet gibt.
Das ist natürlich auch prekär, insbesondere wenn man sich das Verhältnis dieser
beiden Länder anschaut und ohnehin vermutet wird, dass Putin sich ja Belarus
auch gerne nochmal einverleiben würde mittelfristig.
Das ist mehr als Vermutung, da gibt es einen Plan und im Grunde genommen,
ich glaube bis 2030 soll Belarus dann Teil von Russland werden.
Da gibt es viele einzelne Schritte, da gibt es einen riesigen Plan,
das läuft also schon seit längerem.
Also es ist jetzt nichts neues, sondern da finden wohl alle möglichen administrativen
Angleichungen statt und so schon seit vielen Jahren.
Tut ja jetzt erstmal auch nichts zur Sache, das ist jetzt auch noch mal ein
ganz anderes Themenfeld, das machen wir jetzt hier nicht auf,
aber auf jeden Fall, das ist natürlich jetzt eine Erschütterung der Macht.
Weil also wohl Wagner für Russland im Ausland eben wichtige Ressourcen sichert
und viele Konflikte eingebettet ist, insbesondere in Afrika, aber nicht nur dort.
Und Prigoschin ja an der Stelle auch ein Player ist und als Milliardär natürlich
auch irgendwie ganz andere Möglichkeiten hat, noch weiter Ärger zu machen.
Es wird jetzt natürlich auch schon gemunkelt, ob er dann nicht demnächst auch
nochmal näher ans Fenster tritt oder Herzprobleme hat.
Das kann natürlich auch alles sein. Also das ist total offen und da werden wir
die nächsten Tage und Wochen nochmal abwarten müssen. Ich denke nicht,
dass wir den jetzt so schnell verlieren werden in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Zumal ihm ja auch noch Ambitionen nachgesagt wurden, sich zur Präsidentschaftswahl in Russland zu stellen.
Letzten Endes macht es aber so den Eindruck, als ob er seine eigenen Fähigkeiten,
die Möglichkeiten von Wagner und auch seine eigene Popularität im Volk ein bisschen
überschätzt hat und vor allem auch seine Popularität im Apparat.
Also vielleicht hat er damit gerechnet, dass sich noch mehr auf seine Seite
stellen, dass er da sicherer aufgestellt ist und das scheint ihm nicht gelungen
zu sein, weil er dann vielleicht von vielen auch zu sehr als Unsicherheitsfaktor wahrgenommen wird.
Ja, wobei es eine interessante Verschwörungstheorie gibt, die ich eigentlich,
also normalerweise, ja, verbreite ich die ja nicht so gerne,
aber diese ist wirklich zu gut.
Aber die ist zu gut.
Die ist zu gut.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal hier den Modus ändern.
Die ist wirklich einfach zu gut. Und das Schöne ist, dass wir halt bald in ein
paar Monaten wissen werden, ob da was dran ist oder ob das einfach nur Hirngespinst war.
Dann sag mal aber mit dem Disclaimer, jetzt kommt eine Verschwörungstheorie.
Ja, ist eine Verschwörungstheorie, aber Jake Bro hat die vertreten auf eine
sehr charmante Art und Weise.
Einer der YouTuber, die auch daily den Konflikt covern.
Ja, täglich oder alle zwei Tage und so. Aber der hat das halt auch so ein bisschen
mit einem halben Augenzwinkern.
Aber es ist einfach einfach zu schön. Und zwar geht diese Verschwörungstheorie so,
dass angeblich Prigogine Garantien vom FSB,
vom russischen Geheimdienst, erhalten haben soll,
dass er in Ruhe gelassen wird und aus dem Exil für die nächsten Präsidentschaftswahlen
gegen Putin kandidieren darf.
Putin muss sich ja nächstes Frühjahr zur Wahl stellen mal wieder.
Und natürlich geht man davon aus, dass wer auch immer.
Vom Apparat jetzt auserkoren wird zu gewinnen, dann am Ende auch gewinnen wird. und,
Der FSB soll wohl bemerkt oder beschlossen haben, plus andere Teile des Apparats,
dass mit Putin jetzt so nicht weitergeht.
Aber man will jetzt auch keinen Putsch oder so, keine Unruhe und keinen Bürgerkrieg.
Und deswegen ist die ideale Gelegenheit, dann
einfach 2024 bei der Wahl einen neuen Präsidenten zu wählen und dass sich Prigogine
jetzt mit seinem Marsch auf Moskau als Spitzenkandidat des FSB qualifiziert
hat und mit Lukaschenko,
das passt halt auch rein, ich meine klar ist, Lukaschenko ist halt von Putin abhängig,
wäre also Putin gestürzt, wäre das auch das Ende von Lukaschenko gewesen und
mit Sicherheit wären sofort,
also wenn Prigogine weiter marschiert wäre, kann man davon ausgehen,
dass mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit Unruhen in Belarus ausgebrochen wären und
dass das Ende auch von Lukaschenko gewesen wäre. So deswegen hat er sich eben auch reingehängt.
Und jetzt wäre quasi im Rahmen der Verschwörungstheorie ist dann halt Prigushin
deswegen auch bei Lukaschenko und vertraut ihm halt auch,
weil quasi Lukaschenko jetzt so seinen neuen Boss quasi dann kennenlernen kann und die dann schon mal
ein bisschen irgendwie zusammenarbeiten können und es quasi einen Übergang gibt und sagen,
der Deal ist dann auch, dass sozusagen es dann einen geregelten Übergang gibt
und dass Putin einfach abgewählt wird.
Und es gab auch vor einem Jahr, hatten wir ja auch schon mal diskutiert,
dass es ein paar Putin-Kenner gibt, die sagen, dass Putin merken wird,
wenn seine Zeit gekommen ist.
Und dann letztlich friedlich das Feld räumen wird,
dass er eben nicht, ja, dass wenn er merkt,
dass einfach er den Apparat nicht mehr im Griff hat und dass,
dass das sozusagen jetzt auch passiert ist,
oder dass das jetzt klar geworden ist, dass er das nicht mehr im Griff hat und
dass eben einen Machtwechsel jetzt ansteht und dass Prygogine dann sozusagen der neue Mann sein soll.
Und dass auch diese ganze, Verschwörungstheorie muss ja noch mehr,
bisschen mehr dazu packen, dass eigentlich diese ganze Aktion,
also der Kampf um Bachmut ist eigentlich darum ging, Gojin zum Kriegshelden
aufzubauen und dann auch,
ja, diese ganze Symbolik so der,
der furchtlose Kämpfer an der Front und er dann den blutigen Hammer zu seinem
Symbol macht und dann sich versucht, so als ein Mann des Volkes zu gerieren,
der für seine Leute einsteht und sie für Unrecht beschützt.
Und ja, und in der Tat sah es dann auch so aus,
dass er in Rostov teilweise wie einen Rockstar verabschiedet wurde,
was da reinpassen würde, während als dann die Polizei zurückgekehrt ist,
wurde die eben mit Bu-Rufen empfangen, also als die nach Rostov wieder rein ist.
Insofern, gut, wir wissen nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich großflächig ist,
weil es gab jeweils nur wenige Bilder dazu und können natürlich in die Verschwörungstheorie
auch passen, dass sie genau das zu sehen kriegen.
Aber ja, also jedenfalls die Verschwörungstheorie ist,
er will Präsident werden und hat den Rückhalt mittlerweile jetzt im Apparat,
aber nicht für einen Putsch, sondern dass die ihm gesagt haben,
Junge, komm, zieh dich zurück, gib Ruhe,
mach mal irgendwie ein bisschen Pause, geh mal nach Belarus und dann kannst
du halt friedlich im Frühjahr als Präsident kandidieren.
Sozusagen auch Teil des Deals war und dass er eben Garantien dann,
von der Abteilung für Infarkte und Defenestration beim FSB dann auch die Garantie
gekriegt hat, okay, also wir lassen dich dann auch in Ruhe in der Zeit, mach dir keine Sorgen.
Ja, also soweit, wie gesagt, die Verschwörungstheorie und wir werden es ja bald sehen.
Und wenn Prygorjin tatsächlich dann kandidiert und als Kandidat zugelassen werden sollte,
dann waren wir die Ersten, oder nicht die Ersten, aber dann haben wir es gesagt.
Also man wird sehen, aber tatsächlich die Realität ist,
ich meine, Auch so ein Ding ist bei jeder Verschwörungstheorie natürlich,
warum die so attraktiv ist und warum man die glauben möchte,
ist, dass sie die Illusion von Kontrolle erzeugen, dass da jemand ist,
der irgendwie die Sachen im Griff hat und dass da irgendwie das alles dann doch
geleitet und inszeniert wird.
Aber die Wahrheit ist, dass wahrscheinlich niemand genau weiß,
wie das Ganze verlaufen wird.
Prigogine nicht und Putin nicht und auch sonst niemand,
sondern dass die Dinge einfach im Fluss sind und sich entwickeln und ja,
dass das halt hätte gewaltig in die Hose gehen können oder gewaltigere in die
Hose gehen können, als es jetzt in die Hose gegangen ist.
Also die Gefahr jedenfalls, die da drohte,
war immens, weil auch in der Gegend rosthaftaktische Atomwaffen gelagert sind
und man schon befürchtete, dass es jetzt dann zu einem taktischen Nuklearkrieg
auf russischem Boden gekommen wäre.
Was halt auch so ein bisschen die NATO vor gewisse Probleme gestellt hätte,
wenn das passiert wäre. Weil wie reagiert man denn darauf? Ich meine,
darf jetzt Russland nach internationalem Recht denn irgendwie auf eigenem Grund und Boden...
Sich mit Atomwaffen beschießen eigentlich nicht, aber ja wie soll man auf sowas
dann reagieren als NATO?
Das ist ja ohnehin so Teil der Problemkulisse dieses Krieges,
mal ganz unabhängig davon was mit der Ukraine passiert,
das natürlich auch die Frage was passiert mit Russland,
wenn dann alles mal schief gegangen ist, auch alle bewegt,
weil natürlich so ein Land mit soviel Ressourcen, mit soviel mafiösen Strukturen
und ungeklärten Machtverhältnissen in dem Moment wo dann ein Diktator unter
Umständen abtreten muss und irgendeine andere Kaste übernimmt,
dass es ja dann auch sein kann, dass es irgendwie alles noch viel schlimmer wird,
dass sich dann alle bekriegen, dass dann eben daraus dann auch noch sehr viel
mehr Instabilität in alle möglichen Regionen reingeht,
nicht nur jetzt was so das Verhältnis zu den USA betrifft,
Aber mal auch hier zu den Grenzen der ehemaligen USSR Staaten,
Kasachstan, Usbekistan, wenn dann sozusagen auf einmal diese alte Schutzmacht
wegfällt oder zumindest im Turmeul gerät, dass dann eben ganz andere Gruppen losmarschieren.
Hat man ja schon gesehen, der Konflikt zwischen Armenien und Aserbaidschan,
der ist ja auch schon zwischen eskaliert und auch das macht ja den Eindruck,
dass das so nicht passiert wäre ohne den Ukraine-Krieg.
Ähnliche Konfliktbereiche sind natürlich der Norden von Georgien,
also das Gebiet Südössesien und Abkhazien, was ja auch russisch besetzt ist.
Das ist ja im Prinzip dann auch so eine Frage, was passiert dort,
wenn ein Machtvakuum entsteht bis hin eben zu, was ist, wenn jetzt hier so eine
Söldnertruppe übernimmt und auf einmal keine Ahnung was für eine Agenda durchsetzt.
Wir können das jetzt noch ewig diskutieren, vielleicht als letzten Punkt zu
dem Wagner Teil sollten wir uns aber nochmal die Frage stellen,
was macht das jetzt alles mit Putin, weil der ja sozusagen keinerlei wirklich
gutes Bild abgegeben hat und dieses ganze mal eben marschiert da eine Truppe
mit 400 Fahrzeugen auf Russland,
auf Moskau zu und man muss jetzt schon mit nem Bagger die Autobahn aufreißen
um irgendwie noch dagegen vorgehen zu können.
Sicherlich keinen besonders guten Eindruck hinterlassen hat in der russischen Öffentlichkeit.
Also ich meine da sind sich mittlerweile ziemlich alle Beobachter einig ist das,
ja Putins Aura so der Unbesiegbarkeit oder alles im Griff zu haben so einen
massiven Knacks erlitten hat.
Also Putin ist beschädigt und ist signifikant beschädigt, nämlich vor allem
in den Augen der russischen Elite jetzt.
Und diese 24 Stunden,
haben einfach bei vielen die Möglichkeit einer Zukunft oder eines Russlands
ohne Putin das vor Augen geführt.
Das war plötzlich irgendwo in greifbarer Nähe.
Und ich glaube, viele, gerade aus dem Apparat, das ist ja im Grunde genommen,
das Ganze ist ja mehr aufgebaut wie so eine Mafia-Organisation.
Und ja, der starke Führer sieht jetzt nicht mehr stark aus und so ein bisschen
des Kaisers neue Kleider sind jetzt ein Stück weit sichtbar geworden.
Und eigentlich gehen viele davon aus, dass Putin jetzt angezählt ist.
Und wenn jetzt noch mehr Dinge dazukommen, ist es unklar, wie er...
Das wieder einfangen kann oder soll, weil seine Reaktion jetzt,
wie er sich verhalten hat, hat eben einfach Hilflosigkeit und Schwäche offenbart gleich doppelt.
Bei der Rede am Morgen so und bei dem Rückzieher oder Kompromiss,
wie auch immer, der dann am Nachmittag stattfand,
das waren beides nicht, keine Sternstunden für Putin, sondern beide Dinge werden
ihm jetzt mehr oder weniger vorgehalten.
So nicht öffentlich, aber eben einerseits gesagt,
um Hilfe gebettelt zu haben am Morgen und Rache geschworen zu haben,
um dann eben am Nachmittag dann ein,
ja, einem Kumpel durchgehen oder einem ehemaligen Kumpel durchgehen zu lassen,
mal kurz so einen Aufstand angezettelt zu haben und dann,
ja, man offensichtlich dann auch straffrei schon mal sechs Hubschrauber abschießen
und 15 Militärangehörige töten darf,
ohne dafür strafrechtlich belangt zu werden.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Naja jetzt versucht auf jeden Fall Putin Wagner zu demilitarisieren.
Die werden jetzt sozusagen nazifiziert.
Wollen die ganzen Waffen abnehmen. Im Prinzip ist das so das Ende von Wagner
in diesem Konflikt und ob das jetzt Russland in dem Krieg groß hilft da habe
ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Also bisher waren sie ja die fähigste Truppe in dem ganzen Laden,
haben überhaupt noch irgendwas auf die Kette bekommen, aber das weiß ich nicht,
wer die Rolle dann übernehmen soll.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Leute, die jetzt bei Wagner arbeiten,
dass die jetzt alle sich beim russischen Militär verdingen lassen,
vielleicht manche aber sicherlich die meisten nicht.
Also vorher war es wohl so, also Prigogine sagte, ein oder zwei Prozent hätten
vorher unterschrieben beim russischen Verteidigungsministerium.
Also ein paar hundert von 25.000, die angeblich da sein sollen.
Und wie viele jetzt unterschreiben, würde ich auch sagen, das ist grob wahrscheinlich nicht.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich nicht im Staatskonzern arbeiten,
die meisten mit schlechterer Bezahlung und vor allen Dingen ist da halt gerade
so die Frage Vertrauen zur Führung und wie sehr kümmert sich die Führung jetzt
um die Belange der Soldaten und da scheint es tatsächlich so gewesen zu sein,
dass bei Wagner einfach die Dinge besser funktioniert haben.
Und das mal jetzt von den von den Gefangenen abgesehen,
wobei selbst selbst dort ist ja Gruppen gab,
die dann auf seiner Seite standen
oder die dann sogar so von den Ex-Strafgefangenen gab es da welche,
die sich auch zu Wort gemeldet haben, die dann aber richtig sauer waren,
als er den Marsch auf Moskau abgebrochen hat.
Also mit denen hat er sich jetzt auch teilweise so ein bisschen verscherzt,
weil die sich jetzt missbraucht gefühlt haben und die jetzt im Stich gelassen hat.
Ja, sind auch genug in diesem Trupp, die sich dann einfach von diesen ganzen
Umsturzfantasien dann auch sofort elektrisieren lassen und so.
Jetzt stürzen wir den Diktator, zeigt aber auch, dass es Potenzial für Widerstand
gibt gegen Putin, nur muss halt richtig organisiert werden. Das war es jetzt auf Jedenfall nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, es könnte sein, dass eben tatsächlich die Eliten jetzt jemand
anderen wollen und dass sie festgestellt haben,
dass sie mit Putin aus diesem Schlamassel,
den der Ukraine-Krieg darstellt, nicht rauskommen und dass entweder,
und da scheiden sich dann auch die Geister.
Ich meine, die Nationalisten wollen halt richtig eine massive Mobilisierung
und quasi das gesamte, also mehr Richtung totaler Krieg,
während, ja, Teile der Elite endlich wieder normale Geschäfte machen und ins
Ausland reisen wollen und so und eigentlich auch jetzt so langsam die Schnauze
voll haben von diesem Krieg,
weil eigentlich war ja geplant, diese Ukraine zu besetzen und dann sich die
Rohstoffe und Firmen und so untereinander aufzuteilen.
Es sollte eigentlich eine Bereicherung für die russischen Oligarchen werden
und nicht das, was jetzt passiert ist. Also es war irgendwie auch schlechtes Business.
A. War alles ganz anders gedacht eigentlich.
B. Ja. A.
Ja, oh Mist. B.
Ja, also tendenziell, sagen wir mal, die Ereignisse der letzten Woche haben
wahrscheinlich uns einem Kriegsende ein Stück weit näher gebracht.
Aber wie viel?
Wissen wir nicht, aber es ist definitiv erstmal auch positiv für die Ukraine
gewesen, dieser Militäraufstand.
Aber ja, ich hatte dann auch geschrieben,
für die Ukraine wäre es besser gewesen, wenn das weiter eskaliert wäre und er
mehr Schaden angerichtet hätte. die definitiv Schaden angerichtet.
Aber ja, es hätte ein bisschen mehr sein können.
Gut, ich denke an der Stelle können wir hier unseren Rückblick,
Ausblick erstmal beenden.
Das waren so im Wesentlichen die großen Dinge, die passiert sind.
Jetzt werden wir weiter beobachten, wie die Offensive voranschreitet,
ob sie voranschreitet und was den Russen sonst noch alles so einfällt,
verrückte Dinge zu unternehmen.
Ich glaube, da kommt noch so einiges auf uns zu, hoffentlich bewegt sich noch
mehr in Richtung Sieg der Ukraine.
Ich denke, das ist nach wie vor die einzige Option hier in diesem ganzen Spiel
und mit Sieg meine ich halt wirklich die Rückeroberung von allem.
Aber das wird noch ein bisschen dauern.
Also ja, aber so ich sag mal zumindest Verhalten der Optimismus ist glaube ich
weiter gerechtfertigt, aber so Euphorie ist im Moment noch unangebracht.
Aber egal, trotzdem Kopf hoch und wir hören uns dann wieder bald mit dem nächsten
Update, was dann kommt, wenn wir das Gefühl haben, es muss mal wieder alles
zusammengefasst werden von UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald. Ciao.
Macht's gut.